[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
So here in the book of seeking pardon,
seeking forgiveness from
in the chapter regarding
the command of Allah that we seek
forgiveness constantly and the virtues
of the forgiveness of Allah, the pardon
of Allah. What is al
in the Arabic language? If we were to
look at this word,
where does it come from? What what are
its roots?
So,
comes from the three letters.
And these letters when they come in this
order,
they mean to cover something. As a
matter of fact, I'll give you one
better.
Every word in the Arabic language that
starts with the letter
implies some kind of covering.
Every letter, every word,
every word that starts with the letter
as its first letter, it implies some
kind of covering, concealment, something
covering something else.
for instance,
which means for someone to drown. What
is drowning?
That they're swallowed by the water,
right?
anger
which is that a person becomes so angry
they're not thinking straight their mind
isn't seeing clear right
or for instance
or
which is to betray someone
to give them one presentation but really
a plot against them and to betray them
right you're concealing your motives
And likewise, the word
in the Arabic language is to cover
something in a way that protects it.
Is to cover something in a way that
protects it.
So for instance,
the
you know the the helmet that a
soldier would wear
is referred to as a
it's a helmet you put on. It's made out
of iron or something that will protect
or for instance a police station is
referred to as a mur
right because it's a place that is
highly armed and it's where the police
all gather and congregate to protect
themselves and so forth etc. So in the
Arabic language is to conceal
in a protective way.
We take that and we look at the word
when we say in our dua
I am essentially saying oh Allah
conceal my mistakes from others
conceal me from the from the from the
consequences of my bad mistakes
and protect protect me from the fire on
the day of judgment from these
retribution.
This is what
is every time you say
you are saying these three things.
Oh Allah, I seek your protection.
Conceal my mistakes from others.
Protect me from the consequences of my
foolishness
and conceal and pardon these mistakes
from your retribution on the day of
judgment or in this life. That is all in
the one word of
I am seeking from Allah.
And in the Quran often times we find
they're mentioned together right
we say this in our dua
and they kind of go together
and that is because they share a deep
relationship but the point is is that
that is what is when you're seeking a
When you're saying
you're seeking protection from your own
sins and your own bad choices,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in this
verse, verse 106 from
here we have
and mentioned together.
So Allah says to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and seek
from Allah
meaning seek what? Seek pardon and
concealment and protection in Allah from
your sins.
And if you do so when you seek that from
Allah, know that Allah is ever merciful,
ever pardoning.
The scholars say something very
interesting. This is one of the most
interesting aspects of the Quran.
Fascinating
that in the Quran there is a group, a
collection, a family of words
that are referred to as the words that
when they unite they depart and when
they depart they unite.
Interesting, right? What they mean by
this is
words that when they're mentioned
together they mean different things. So
when they unite, they're mentioned
together. They depart in their meanings.
But when they depart, meaning when they
are mentioned separately, they unite in
their meanings. Each one means the
other. They're synonymous. Examples of
this are all through the Quran.
Islam,
many many many groups of words that fall
into this category. When they're
mentioned together, they mean separate
things. But when they're mentioned
separately, they mean what? The same
thing.
If I were to say only a Muslim will
enter paradise
or if I were to say only a m will enter
paradise. Are those two statements
correct?
Yeah, they mean the same thing because
Islam means im and im means Islam when
they're mentioned separately. But when I
say them together
now they mean something different. like
the famous narration of Ji. Tell me
about Islam. He mentions the five
pillars of Islam. Tell me about Eman. He
then mentions the six pillars of Eman.
They meant separate things then.
So the point here is that
when you say oh Allah
it means
and when you say on its own it means
however and they're mentioned together
is for the past
and is for the future.
So when you say
together, what you're really saying is,
"Oh Allah, conceal my past. Cover it.
Protect me from it. Protect me from my
own silly actions, from my own
foolishness.
and protect me in the future what is to
come. Have mercy on me. Don't allow me
in the future to get carried away with
my foolishness. So when the words are
together
is for the past and is for the future.
And this goes for the names of Allah.
Alafur ale.
When Allah's name al is mentioned it
entails ale. And when alheim is
mentioned, it entails. But when they're
mentioned together,
they mean the same. They mean different
things.
So Allah is saying,
seek forgiveness from Allah.
Indeed, Allah is the forgiving, the
pardoning. If you seek from Allah
forgiveness, he will forgive you.
He will forgive you guaranteed
as long as you know how to seek
forgiveness which is what this chapter
[Arabic recitation]
Looks he was at or he was shopping
at Costco.
[Arabic recitation]
you were at Costco.